[Music]  kim kardashian and kanye west's family's  newest addition has a name  Chicago West the name obviously has  special meaning to Kanye he was born and  raised in the Windy City Chicago I'm  sorry I had to go to the cowboy boots up  you live in LA too long and according to  aunt Chloe the family will call her shy  for short  along with the name announcement Kim  also revealed Chicago's a birth weight  on her app she came into the world at  just seven pounds six ounces but still  no first look at Kim yeas little girl  who was born via surrogate knowing that  I was able to carry my first two babies  and not you know my baby now that is  hard for me so it's definitely a harder  experience than I anticipated if I could  do it myself I would have preferred that  so that's a little like that inner  struggle is kind of hard but I'm just  rolling with it and it is what it is  [Music]  you